and a pink dank dank dank dank
Johnny looking at a murmur oh there's a
worm in our caterpillar but it's not a
cute one you're almost talking with with
wildlife and little insects like that
why you guys talk about this one cuz
he's I don't know what he's doing here
he just wants to be here for a podcast
you're like I look I know if you I've
been renting my entire adult life like
I'm really tired of it and I would like
my own house some days I don't have to
put up with this there's like an inch
gap behind that door that goes to
outside like he just crawled in here on
it
I like his initiative no you just chill
it on the floor but why is he here maybe
since he wants little toys and treats
that were sent to us by barkbox this
epsilon I J Jillian podcast is brought
to you by barn box fire segue off the
top what is mark box well for humans
bark box is a delivery of four to six
natural treats and super fun toys
curated around the surprise theme of
each month for dogs bark BOTS is the joy
of a million belly scratches they've
crate it's a monthly subscription box
that you can design what kind of things
come for your dog treats toys what size
your dog all that sort of stuff you
completely customize it it comes every
month and it's really great I mean some
of the toys that are have like lasted
that you know the Tet the test of time
with peaches teeth are the bark box toys
the and they're able not only peaches
favorite but any dog that comes to visit
they choose those over other dog toys
Firefox makes quality stuff yeah totally
when you are yeah they will fight over
that and it doesn't get destroyed right
now guys you can get a free extra month
of bark box by going to bark box calm
slash Jenna Julianne when you subscribe
to a 6 or 12 month plan that's bark box
calm slash annejulien Thank You bark box
thank you bye our other sponsor this
week is a new sponsor and it is hey the
skin and skin is a free email newsletter
that breaks down what's going on in the
world every week it's fun easy
informative and it makes it easier to be
smarter I like free and I'm smarter
smarter
and easy to be smarter so you like your
cutting corners here it's good stuff but
for real the scheme is awesome like a
life producer did you miss meet your new
morning routine with the scam right now
guys you can enter to win a two hundred
and fifty dollar Visa gift card by going
to this skim with two M's the skim two
M's comm slash Jenna Julian that's the
skin SK IMM calm sighs Jenna Jillian and
you can enter for your chance to win
right now oh thank you so much sponsors
nope don't [ __ ] up I'm like I can't I
can't concentrate with him here he's so
gross he's not Allah verily I will raid
his face off when we're done shooting
his podcast I'm gonna rape I'm gonna
look him in the eye and say hey what do
you have to live for and he's gonna look
at me and be like you know what's and
then I'm gonna rate him in the face oh
I'm just like so confused though like
it's a worm and it's next to me like a
caterpillar like don't it's not like I
looked over there and there's like three
caterpillars on their way in like
hanging out it's just one caterpillar
what is he doing he's just going against
the grain
pun intended he's on the wood I hate him
like I'm cool with bugs I'm like just
not in my space
you know like spider is fine but like if
you touch me you're gonna die
I'm sorry if that thing should I go yet
I just a nylon you know Julie thing
thought you loved me come on be funny
oh you should I compressed air down
towards you oh my god okay
did you hear no oh you're I thought
Julian has a problem spraying the
compressed air have you sprayed
compressed air it's the most fun thing
I've ever done holding or there's like a
red straw that comes out of the can that
you can spray your electronics I clean
wet dust cleaner yeah but if you spray
it at something close and long enough it
it's like it freezes it yes brought yeah
but you have to spray it upside down in
order to do that even he did that to my
wine glass when we were in there
drinking wine and he thought it was so
funny and he like made it wet and then
it went away and I was like Julian this
tastes like pure chemicals now but was
it chill I mean it made you take a sip
of it because you didn't
yes no it's good thank you you know you
like an amateur you didn't cover the top
when I was cooling your beverage I hyper
oh please I didn't ask for it I didn't
want it I didn't want to participate in
it when you enter the tornado kitchen
and living room and I don't relax it's
the tornado Bar and Grill oh and with a
drink if we will not allow your drink to
get any warmer than 65 Celsius as that
gold is that I don't know
that's like boiling hot else we got a
boiling hot beverages cocktail circuit
sizzling burns your whole mouth oh you
sick I am sick and I need Jesus but good
thing I have jesus's pocket cheesy sit
all right so that means nothing by the
way I always say that you sit you need
Jesus it's okay you don't are caduceus
it's not just take what it is all right
anyways it means something I have pocket
jeans it's okay Papa cheese screaming
alright moving into questionable
territory we it's likely to be a sort of
podcast so thank you for understanding
but we are going to do a debate cast
today I'm going with some of the hottest
most pressing most important topical
issues that we could ever debate and we
are going to debate them here on this
podcast so what we've done is we made
the list of the statements and one of us
is gonna argue argue Pro that's Damon
the others going to argue against that
statement and we've already determined
who's going to be Pro and against each
statement so should we just get into it
can you remind me yellow means that I'm
arguing for against against got it you
ready mm-hmm
are the holidays fun no yes no yes okay
I'm going to start it off go ahead first
of all just because I'm saying no
doesn't mean there aren't aspects of the
holidays that I enjoy there are very
very very special and nostalgic and fun
feelings that come along with the
holiday season the hot chocolate
the
you know red cops the Christmas lights
everywhere the Christmas music got to so
you already made my voice abundantly
caught I will tell you the idea of
meeting up with your family only to
exchange gifts of which are terrible
because you don't see them in since last
Christmas it's been a whole year likely
for a lot of people not me I don't know
it sounds like a kind of weak argument
you spend all this time away from your
family and you're like oh it's Christmas
I get to see my family
let's go out and spend a whole bunch of
money on [ __ ] that they are not going to
like 1,000% I'm going to hate myself for
doing it because I'm standing in line in
a miserable store full of miserable
people trying to get through their
miserable day I mean we went Christmas
shopping and it wasn't that bad but I
also hated it and I think what Christmas
and the holidays are it's glorification
of consumerism and I think that's [ __ ]
am I ready to speak now I don't know are
you ready oh yeah they're fun
one word say it da+
also if you expand the word holiday that
means like vacation in other people's
cultures like Australian yeah are you on
holiday yeah
holidays are fun that means you get to
get drunk and hang out on holiday and be
in your pajamas it says holidays I'm
allowed to interpret this argument
however I want wow that's a loophole
vacation holidays I like a good holiday
no holidays are fun no when I'm on
holiday that's a good holiday when it's
the holidays for everyone it does not
matter bonus are the holidays there's
such a [ __ ] you know a man holidays are
fun ok even if it's dull holiday which
block ok we're assuming you're meaning
whatever winter holiday your self
Christmas yeah it's fun you to hang out
with your family who's awesome and watch
your parents get drunk which is awesome
I think what is going to be in your
pajamas I think once a year people
should definitely get together and see
their families but not do all the dumb
[ __ ] that people do for the holidays so
who's the winner how are we deciding I
think you want
I kind of like the hot yes all right you
got that you got no I mean keep in mind
that we're forced to take pro and con
decided this yeah all right
someone might have a stronger argument
all right debate number two
I'm just keeping score is a scooter a
useful practical mode of transportation
[ __ ] yeah in my position is [ __ ] no okay
let's have you go for a scooter why is
this good or not trip practical or
useful because when I wrote this I was
thinking of a razor scooter it's not
appropriate for transportation
whatsoever did it is for fun riding
around the cul-de-sac that you live in I
would have you know because whoever
bought that for you definitely lives in
a cul-de-sac in his disposable income to
buy such a stupid piece of [ __ ] first of
all don't associate razor students with
disposable income those are not high
tech high so whoever gets their paycheck
and is like oh [ __ ] okay
rent paper towels food and a new razor
scooter no one prioritizes their money
that way there's not a soul on this
train is that a name one I can name one
money because not disposable on a razor
scooter no one bought that out of
necessity no nation who quick shout out
to my boy Matt Jones from Australia he
rides around time lapse in in Australia
on a scooter I'm gonna raise your
student a [ __ ] razor school it's just
like that's he states he scoots out with
his giant backpacking dry and tripod and
lives around Sydney and he and he goes
to the harbour he goes to the Opera
House he City scooters on to the Train
like around from his house all the way
to the harbour circular key wherever you
got wherever the sunset is he's
scootering away
I've watched him do it on snapchat and
it's impressive I've lost so much
respect for him get a skateboard or some
[ __ ] not last man is putting their their
hands at like mid-thigh
to all the little vandals
it's good what professional does I'm
sorry if you've written a scooter and
you got good at you know that you can
press her hips up against the handlebars
in your hands-free yeah what do you want
to ride a skateboard because the the the
preconceived notions of people who think
you're a deviant if you're on a
skateboard
what's wrong with the but it's so clunky
you can't put that thing in your
backpack you fold a scooter up does your
bike fold in half they do make models
that fold in half
that's like saying they make cars that
fly yes they make a few of them those
are called airplanes okay cars that run
on water that's called the boat cars
they should not on where they run fuel
bhismaka because just running on cars
that run on Rails close all the Tree
Grows legs and runs on water you sick I
definitely won that one skills wait
rocket you help me plug this in and
can't see who unknown way I win oh gosh
scooters are practical you said name one
soul who buys it out of necessity and I
made that soul is garbage it's not
carbon it's garbage I win I thought you
were gonna at least expand into like
motorized scooters though okay I'll get
me to get me started on that I mean
that's another hole I'll give you
motorized scooter all right I can't
believe you actually named a person that
rides a razor scooter around yeah chosen
form of turn oh yeah that is trash
hmm-hmm-hmm
I got you how old is he Matt I'm Matt
Holly um he's like 30 no way yeah ask
him he's probably awake it's Australia
time hello all right I guess you want
sure go ahead
thank you okay next next debate if
someone calls you a [ __ ]
you should punch them I'm the one that
has yes on this you got us on this okay
yeah so like good
where are your argument um I mean it's a
tough one but the only way I can
logically say
as to this is if you apply all of prison
rolls to the world if someone it's if
you cause them on a [ __ ] it's like the
worst thing you can call someone into
automatic fighting words yeah there it's
like saying it lace up so these actually
we we watched 60 days in okay we know
what we're talking about
I know so you're saying you're applying
those rules to life
everyone prison rules so you just gave a
stipulation your argument that makes it
completely invalid no yeah you did know
is that one gonna be talking to someone
who was nothing to do with jail that's
that's irrelevant doesn't apply to them
prison rules if someone called you a
[ __ ] in the world and everyone just
punched that person the world would be a
madhouse and you would get you're
getting fights every single day everyone
would be bruised up all the time
everyone would be in jail what is there
what is the government do okay
the theoretical question is say the
government tried to enforce some
[ __ ] law and like everybody ended up
in jail what would happen like if
everyone broke the law what would happen
they wouldn't be able to house that many
people ain't such as what happened like
the economy would be destroyed because
no one could work no one could do their
guns there would be also a casual mutiny
happening yeah what would happen that's
not the question has not even close to
that don't don't do that you were losing
the argument so you just started no one
I say yes I say that's fine I think the
fact that your argument is prison rules
is because I'm right means that you're
completely [ __ ] wrong completely
[ __ ] wrong all right I just looking
at that [ __ ] caterpillar guy he's
calling you a [ __ ] what do you do about
it
all right you win that by the way my
hair is actually blonde this week it's
not keyed out from the green screen this
is real color color maramon you're an
excellent you know important details
about things okay so I'd say I won that
one fine right guys right right guys
guys guys is anyone there
all right next one are squirrels stupid
do you have yes or no no I have yes but
I'll argue either no tell me how stupid
they're okay one word cars what because
they get hit by cars and the time that I
wrote over one with my bike and split in
that's fun don't say that to me I did
know I know you did just don't say it it
was an accident
because when they're endangered no
listen here's why squirrels are stupid
dare listen you you squirrels are stupid
because when they're in danger they
don't know which direction to go like
curves and you're trying to walk by him
he's like oh [ __ ] let's get in your way
you've run somehow in every direction
that's why squirrels are stupid have you
seen a squirrel eat a nut it is it is a
the miracle is one of the seven wonders
well no wonder they get into probably
ones in the world over it's nothing but
a billion it's an eighth wonder of the
world
okay that's really standing up on its
hind legs
that's not how squirrels eat you're
telling me in your mind right now when
you picture a squirrel eating they're
standing up yeah you know like hunched
over their stay they like they're
crawling run and they're like no no no
that's it that's that's a squirrel no
they if you accept that they get into
bird feeders then yet how fast can you
climb a tree so fast
here-here's climb a tree that fast that
doesn't make them smart maybe you're
stupid here's another reason why
squirrels are stupid so in Boston when I
used to live like right near the common
I lived on Tremont Street there was a
hawk that lived in the common the people
are always so shocked by this such a
giant jarring bird for the middle of
Abuja travelers charing bird okay sure
the squirrels there are so tame from all
people selling like roast nuts and
feeding the squirrels and like on the
Boston Common
so you could literally walk like through
the boss and calm and go and squirrels
would start like running up to you don't
touch you they'll come right here gnarly
it because people feed them in there
yeah so this one [ __ ] hawk just
figured out that those squirrels are so
dumb and so tame all that Hawk did was
just sit in a tree and post up and
decide which dumb squirrel to eat that
day and I would see people walk like
pass it all the time at this Hawk in the
middle of a beautiful park in Boston
just ripping up a new squirrel every day
so people are like oh my god what is it
doing
no it's the smartest bird that there is
it barely even has a hunt or look for
food you so what you're seeing is a
squirrel isn't stupid it's just dumber
than a very smart bird no they're done
the question is are squirrels stupid
Julian let me ask you a question Julian
let me ask you a question say you're
Bill the squirrel and you had a whole
family of like eight other squirrels and
every day you saw a different family
member kidding just make old and dead in
the park and you were maybe not smart
either they are not done and go to a
buffer area so that you could live that
is the epitome of stupid all right
they're dumb where are you in that one
yes finally God girls are dumb you
actually saw a hawk
let go out and [ __ ] get these scrubs
yes you watched it yes cuz I would walk
through the cookies like tear it up yes
so I would walk through the comment to
go to class from my dorm and it would be
like in the middle of the pathway and
people are like taking pictures of it
like shocked like oh what is it doing
here and like of course it hangs out
here of course it lives here
this food is endless supply what do look
look at the site did it look like he was
enjoying the scroll East yeah yeah was
it like delicious like a barkbox treat
for your dog that you would get turn oh
my god a clone guy's bark box is amazing
okay it's a delivery of four to six
natural treats and super fun toys
curated around each theme which bark box
rotates each month you can choose a plan
one six or 12 month plans are available
cancel anytime and it's free shipping
boxes are shipped on the 15th of each
month every month they
pick the best all-natural treats an
innovative toys to match a dog's unique
needs including allergies and heavier to
preferences so if you have chompers on
your dog like peach has even though
she's still small you can choose heavier
chewing preferences so treat so the toys
won't just get destroyed right away hmm
it's a great way to try a different
variety of treats without being
overwhelmed it going to the store not
knowing what to pick out barkbox does
the work for you in each monthly boxes
themed like I said there's count there's
like a County Fair bark ball Pooh York
City
Brooklyn hipster stuff like that I'm
telling you some of these toys are sore
about liking really well-designed and if
your dog doesn't like one of the barkbox
toys they will send you back something
that you will like on your pet will like
for free that is the barkbox guarantee
and they are free shipping all of the
continental US when when your dog falls
falls in love with something from the
box you can easily find it again on the
barkbox shop or the app which you can
get on your phone right now guys go to
barkbox calm slap down is when you get
it free extra month when you sign up for
a 6 or 12 month plan that's BA R KBO
XCOM slash Jenna Julianne Thank You
barkbox our other sponsor this week is
the skin guys it's you really don't have
to read all the news just to get the the
pieces that you really need and want the
skin does all that work for you they
curate the top news stories and they
create an email newsletter that breaks
down what's going on so what's a
headline meryl streep
at the at the golden globes was talking
about how MMA and football choose a
little bit talking [ __ ] about that so
that's a headline that's something lying
about yeah but you know what's another
headline uh I don't know there's there's
been a Mariah Carey you didn't want to
miss that right like if you want your
stuff curated you don't have to dig
through all the news a lot of the
irrelevant and kind of click baby things
that are put on news now you need help
and the skin can really help you with
that right now if you just help you
focus so you don't fall down deep holes
of progress and it keeps you online true
and you can choose your interests
whether politics sports entertainment
whatever else you want this game has all
information you need to know to start
your day right now just go to the skim
that's th es ki mm that's two M's comm
slots Jenna Julianne and your email and
click Subscribe it's that simple you'll
receive your first email from the skim
the following morning and there's a lot
of stuff to keep up with so there's
constantly new changing information that
you're going to get right now you can
int you can enter yourself to win a $250
Visa gift card just by signing up and
subscribing you go to the skin with two
M's comm /n Julian and you can enter
yourself to win a 250 dollar Visa gift
card that's like cash guys it's like a
cash basket thank you skin thank you so
much the skin I got check that out
there's nothing like it
sorry Julian alright alright so next
question is retreated to what is the
score yeah I think it's two to two or
something like maybe do chinchillas make
good pets my position is no yes they can
go get your food no they can yes have
you seen a chinchilla can't they either
got hot dog and they spin another thing
about I hand it to you it's amazing go
up no I say no because they don't they
bring you food they don't they do
no they do no you can also just leave it
in its cage and never feed it food or
water and it'll survive forever that is
a lie but these are all facts I've had
some shows people only I feel like
people only buy two gels because they're
super soft but they don't they're not
good pets they bite if you let them out
of their cage they'll just run away and
hide Jenna Jenna where the chinchilla is
we can't find them [ __ ] I don't [ __ ]
know I'm just babysitting you like that
alright I'm I mean I'm in lost territory
here I'm gonna concede
you get that one yes but strategy flip
our rainbows real my position is no
they're real how are they real their
reflection of fragments of light in the
in the light spectrum going on that the
human eye can see reflections fragments
light oh they are all real things they
are all real things rooted deep in
science nope they're not real it's not a
real thing just because you can't
physically touch it doesn't mean it's
fake yes it does okay if I fart and you
can't touch it does that make that part
they get fun farts so real right now
that users can see this argument
rainbows are fake they're not saying yes
they are fake I mean they're not fake
they're really sorry they're real I just
know they're not fake but they're not
real you can't touch them they're made
and I just and I just stuff of life I
just poke a hole in that argument of you
can't touch it therefore it's not real
good come on if you can't touch body
odor does that mean that [ __ ] at work
who comes in and sits next year it
doesn't have body odor no means it's
just maybe that's what you want to smell
like maybe he's anti your deodorant
you're in a different argument now it's
his decision no you're acknowledging the
Bo which means it's real all right fine
all right fine rainbows are real I just
like that question are rainbows real
okay next one should cursive like
writing in cursive be made illegal
I think definitely yes my position is
though definitely yes first of all if
you write in cursive how dare you what's
the penalty then you get ah and if it's
a legal I made you the way that you are
to do something like that to me just
really I'm victimized if it's illegal
what's the penalty if someone writes in
cursive music illegal easy chop off a
finger every time someone's caught doing
it that way if they break it the rule
enough times they will not be able to
write in cursive what about with their
mouth chopped off mouth good you sick I
am sick that's nasty
it should not be illegal because it's a
beautiful art form
it is the dumbest waste of shitty
[ __ ] time that I wasted in the third
grade and was told it was going to make
my life success what do you think that
about like calligraphy calligraphy is is
beautiful that is an art and that not
everyone can do that just not cursive
cursive is not calligraphy what's the
difference
calligraphy is a use with a different
pen that emphasizes thin and thick edges
as the stroke is being made those edges
change and morph you can do that with
cursing you abso-fuckin'-lutely cannot
and let me tell you something having
actually learned calligraphy that [ __ ]
is not easy I know it's not you win ok
no you just said I win there's no
returning from ice it's ok your fingers
got off if you do it yeah it's a
reasonable it's a reasonable punishment
for offense god what is why what compels
a person to be such a horrible person to
write cursive what compels a person he
just pulled both mics into his I needed
to say something fine cursive is now
illegal thank you
be careful all right is the word
pretentious pretentious no yes no it is
no yes it is oh if the word pretentious
is pretentious everything ever is
pretentious no if you call something
pretentious you're pretentious enough to
call something pretentious therefore
your protecta and so Michael it creates
literally an infinite number of
pretentious things well yeah no but
that's not the case not everything is
pretentious you shouldn't throw the
first stone and call something
pretentious you're being pretentious how
would you know if something is
pretentious if you cannot say it's
pretentious how do you how do you even
know what that word means it's just it's
a long unnecessary word to insult
something really it's not an insult so
everyone it's a pretentious insult and
it's pretentious oh you're pretentious
that word is pretentious oh you're
pretentious why cuz you just called it
pretentious well then yeah and so am i
cuz I just called you pretentious yes
and you're watching
you're pretentious pretentious the word
is pretentious yep not using it not like
using the word isn't pretentious the
word itself is pretend yes is that the
argument yeah is the word pretentious
pretentious yes so is someone able to
use the word pretentious without being
pretentious yes you can ones that
weren't even way anymore can you could
use a different word you don't have to
say pretentious if I'm being a
pretentious prick
call me pretentious without calling me
pretentious wow that was not cool not
cool is so broad I don't know dude seems
like you're dragging down two people
right now time Cantus if I say wow that
is pretentious wow that was pretentious
that word is pretentious you don't have
to say it's like saying dumb is a dumb
word like that word is dumb yeah I don't
wear dumb just put it up is dumb no it's
not that only further supports my
argument there is no Arg
that's like saying the word wet is wet
it is it's wet no it's not it's a word
it's a combination of three others are
real okay you were back to I'll give you
this one right thank you
[ __ ] all y'all all right [ __ ] dogs wear
clothes my position is what is mine yes
I know I'm saying no okay I say yes I
say no I'm here yes I say no okay my
argument for yes is sometimes they're
cold or maybe dogs appreciate sweaters
or jackets like marble he really
appreciates a his little spider-man
shirt he loves that thing he gets an
extra little pep in his step he gets
excited he feels confident in it and I
on the other hand you have my dog who's
rearranging our living room furniture
because she's walking underneath it
because she's so itchy from wearing a
t-shirt okay maybe she shouldn't but
sometimes you know it's yes or no there
is not some there is all dogs were one
sweater at the same time or none ever
that's not the question just think back
to this know it says should dogs wear
clothes if they want to what about a
work vest a work messes and clothes to
work vest
why would a dog mean work vest a service
dog they have them they say service dogs
yeah so I'm saying is that is that under
the umbrella of clothes
yeah no it's not it's a work fest
[ __ ] work
no no closes those is that little furry
[ __ ] thing that you bought from our
place that's close a work best is yeah
they should be able to wear clothes I
like I like dog clothes right fine I'm
fine
you [ __ ] win that one yes it's your
winning five before next question are
can you trust the beauty community I
think you mean on YouTube I say yes okay
here's my argument for why you can trust
to be a community their videos are so
pretty and the lighting is so
trustworthy and fluorescent and their
makeup is so pretty and they're pretty
and I trust them all of them and my
position is no and everything they're
telling you is completely honest why
would they lie my position is no because
I feel like I recently have watched way
too many videos exposing the beauty
community some of them for doing some
shady stuff man well I think if I was in
the boat of like this person can sell me
anything all the time then I was like
wait a second that affiliate code that
you just told me will give me 10% off
that money goes into your pocket a court
girl of course you love this product
diet market you can paid and you don't
have to say sponsored cuz it's a hi
Elliot high definition affiliate code
means that you are getting a piece of
whatever you're selling but if you tell
that to a 13 year old no I'm not gonna
no but I think the beauty community is
just as guilty as a lot of the other
communities on YouTube for being kind of
tricky like that
so no we can't trust them even though
they're pretty and their lighting is
pretty though you can trust some of them
park you're winning some of them you
can't chose winning something or gotten
caught and [ __ ] right here's the next
question that's a good question
our cats okay I don't think they're okay
my position is yes I don't think they're
okay in the sense of like is that cat
okay like that cat is not okay no cats
are okay
in their own mind and well-being and
be are they okay to have around society
allowing this is are they okay no to
both
I say yes no cats are cats are cool no
yeah great no they make great friends
no they absolutely don't they're
solitary beat they are solitary people I
think that they're mentally sound
they're really good they will tear your
face off of your face always crying yeah
let's not reward him by opening her all
right you know you're gonna win this one
because they're not okay I'm not okay
okay and you know what they they can be
okay but are they okay no no they are
not you know that when you're pregnant
you can't change kitty litter because
you can get something called
toxoplasmosis from their feces that will
create birth defects cats kill babies
they're not okay God doing it sorry
Julian yes what is such a ridiculous pun
yes sentence our cats okay the answer is
always no even if I'm a cat person I'm
gonna be like no they're not are you
talking to see the cat have you seen a
cat bat the [ __ ] out of another human
being to the point where it has to get
surgery and [ __ ] fix his eye they're
not okay I don't know if you've ever
tried to argue a position that you
really don't care about yeah it's
difficult it's hard okay I like this
podcast I we should do this it is fun if
you guys think if you guys have any
different like topics we can do this
again for we'll do it again
all right we have a few more robust room
our child leashes problematic how the
[ __ ] yeah they are you're putting your
knife position is more human on a leash
like a slave and you're tugging at him
you sit you're a kid why you didn't know
because the Grand Canyon what like
imagine you have a gun that is a lot
energy and you're in a place that's kind
of dangerous you call it a lot of energy
I call it
dog Darwin Award [ __ ] run off if you
love that much energy sure yeah and
we'll weed out the worst no it's your
responsibility as a package Julianne
it's your sponsor we need to get that
kid exercise so he doesn't go to the
Grand Canyon with excess energy and
she's not to bother leash to prevent
your child from offing himself at the
tallest Canyon on earth oh this is such
a problematic question even in of itself
those child leashes me I'm so
uncomfortable if I see one at if I hit
the wall at the mall
I see [ __ ] them at the mall all the
time these parents are like on their
maiden family or like they need I don't
even want to look at these stupid kid
maybe that parent feels like they need
them I stop talking you kid around just
stop it
if you want them to do something help
them do it
don't tug them around an animal all
right who wins this I won't lose come on
okay you can win right there child leech
is a problem in a problem an according
to Julian six to six and our fake
positions on this um
are you ever truly alone no yes
my position is no until spoiler alert
got black mirror spoiler until goes
click away your implanted like half of
the episodes of black mirror in some way
shape or form there are ways to get get
a lot of get along yes yes I'm sorry yes
there's not every square inch on the
planet that's covered by microphones or
cameras you can go out into the desert
and sit in a hole and be alone yes yes
yes
what about spirits at the terrestrials
ghosts what about if all the theories of
the universe that you know maybe you're
in a matrix and your body is somewhere
else and this is all just an illusion
said three-name you have said the words
series and maybe in your day that you're
never truly alone ok so you think every
square inch-- literally and figuratively
on earth
is covered by something whether it's a
spirit doesn't have to be cutting in
what if someone can just tap into your
consciousness then you're not alone are
you you just said what if that's not an
argument you're just literally exploring
potential idea that could be right
Julian you can be truly alone sometimes
fine you win if you go on to the desert
and you dig a little hole and you sit in
the hole you have to be in a hole 9 to
be a wasn't this ground level is not
safe you got a little lower you're alone
no one's there oh this is such trash
we're both just like reaching so far
alright you can win that one alright
alright next - I don't know what
happened to my government okay let's get
that one let's see this one is telling
people you can do anything you put your
mind to
responsible my position on this is No
yeah yeah no it is not responsible
because some people can't do it but what
if they really want to be inspired this
isn't mad this is this question is
addressing what PewDiePie was talking
about the force positive [ __ ] but I mean
it's a good question like is is saying
you can do anything
is that a responsible thing to tell
people whether they're kids or other
people whatever mmm
high personal 'hey i'm gonna have a
really hard time arguing yes because i
think it's irresponsible hmm i think can
be irresponsible not all the time
i think sometimes it's important to
inspire others and chase your dreams and
everything always you always lean
positive if you can but when it gets to
the point of doing that for ulterior
reasons also Narron a false narrative
you're giving you're giving hope to
people where there shouldn't be hope
given it's like a it's a it's an
unhealthy way to them we've had i feel
like we've had this discussion about
like like life coaches like a Tony
Robbins yes I think we have you talked
about your sort of feeding off of people
that are they really need help in that
moment in their life and they're really
seeking someone with answers because
when you're in some sort of like crisis
in your life what may be some crisis
just like dark time
not with for some people is all the time
yes no you just what makes you feel
better is when someone has an answer for
you so I think that that's what some of
these people serve as their purpose and
they know that yeah they take advantage
of it that's when it's not good that's
when I feel like you're preying on
people that are seeking to feel better
because they genuinely need an answer
friend and you can see that because a
lot of times you can kind of understand
that the person saying that has
something to gain by preaching that you
look at someone I mean this is a
completely random example but someone
like Mark Cuban right
this guy made himself a billionaire
mm-hmm from being a very very poor
immigrant in poor immigrant family right
his family was mark using I think he was
in a immigrant family I think because
you know Robert Herjavec was yeah he
talks about it all the time but one
another point the point is the point is
if you were to talk to Mark Cuban and
you're like you know you need advice
wherever he would say you can [ __ ] do
it like you you it doesn't matter if you
have nothing right now save your pennies
have an idea work hard and you can get
there that's him saying it because he
lived that mm-hmm
it's not him saying oh you can do
anything it's him saying no you if you
work hard you [ __ ] work hard it
doesn't matter where you are right now
because I was I was really low I had
nothing and I made something mm-hmm I
think a situation like that is more
appropriate well there's a I guess what
you're proposing is there's a fine line
because everyone in theory thinks that
that's what they're saying
no no because a lot of it's so broad
well yeah like you can do anything
that's right all right yeah we're both
on the same page but all right so do we
get a point we both get 10 points okay
what's lazier never putting up a
Christmas tree or never taking it down
so I've never putting it down never
taking it down as lazier and mine is
never putting one up
you never put up your Christmas tree
that's lazy how are you supposed to have
the holidays no lazy lazy and that's
letting that I got that thing so
inappropriate sit around your house yeah
nothin you know October already way me
when you move I can't argue this I can't
argue this never taking down your
Christmas true story my life is no easy
thing I've ever loved all right next one
Ronda Rousey could beat up a kangaroo
never in a million years no I say yes no
literally I say yes okay let's just in a
world where she somehow gets in tight
enough to clinch a kangaroo witch's we
are all on the same page her only chance
at winning is if she puts this thing on
her on its back and she's saying she's
not gonna strike the kangaroo today uh
no she's not gonna strike a kangaroo at
first she needs to beat level 0 which is
humans and then level 100 she can be by
a boxing kangaroo did know kangaroos are
[ __ ] feisty yeah they're badass
lean on their tail kick you they punch
you then I'm gonna [ __ ] so we all know
that she can't out strike Vicky I feel
like yeah but you could also just do
some weird [ __ ] to a kangaroo
cuz they're kind of weird like you could
just run up to it and like scream really
loud at it and it just might get so
weirded out my guy just punched a
kangaroo the guys there in the mouth um
I I think humans can absolutely be
humorous I had something Ronda Rousey
Ken I think she I just think her fight
style is gonna go it's not built for a
king every time
no hearse fights out she needs to get in
tight clinch him throne get on them I
mean choking whatever right she can't
get in that magazine
right to the teeth so she's like what
she 135 fighting but like probably 150
155 walking around yeah easily but you
and I both seen a kangaroo that hurts
like 250 DMS yes dude good just I like
weight alone I'd say you're probably I
could train my entire life's went to you
specifically trying to beat a kangaroo
and I could still get my ass not talking
specifically specific kangaroo training
that's some [ __ ] done
all right so I won you did I'm 9 to 6 no
9 to 7 you won that that one whatever
last one
dogs have sexy hamstrings easily yes my
position is now they're the sexiest
hamstrings especially greyhounds like
racing dogs oof oh boy
my position is know why because you
sorry it is an actual fact that their
hamstrings are so built and so strong
and so functional hyper functional none
of that argues your point are sexy very
sexy what's sexy about a dog's hamstring
it looks like it's just perfectly curved
I mean it's not sexy in a sense that
like I want to sex it it's like it's
just a sexy thing it's like like in
rocket league right I'll go up and I'll
shoot a great aerial goal flipping
around in the air and goes in I'm like
wow I was sexy I don't want to have
intercourse with the goal anything
that's possible but it was a sexy goal
just like the hamstrings on some of
these dogs they can run fast
it looks good their dynamic these dogs
some of these dogs not all these dogs
what's an example of a dog that doesn't
have a sexy hamstring uh have you seen
wiener dogs oh wow okay their bodies
that is being read and their hamstring
is like that day or add readest
[ __ ] wiener dogs if you're a wiener dog
I'm sure they're wonderful I raised one
for like years it was itchy mm-hmm
what's wrong with you I had a really
really neglectful neighbor that made his
wiener dog incredibly fat and it scarred
me and from then on like wiener dogs hot
his belly dragged on the good sides that
Sun is falling I picked him up in there
Barry's on his belly that's really sad I
was terrible he let him out like once
every couple days go pee on the front
this is so terrible
he's so fat I told you like when a sir I
forget what it was but it was either
working at the shelter or like looking
at dogs in a shelter because that's what
I used to do for fun there were signs on
all of their kennels
and like every dog had like a little
folder with information about the dog or
whatever and then there were two very
overweight dachshunds in one kennel
together and instead of a folder with
information it was just like a paper
sign that said we're obese with an
exclamation point goods all it said I
can't leave you like go up to them and
pet them and they're both just like
who's excited
we Robi we are obese I wish I had a sign
like that on front of my forehead
someone would just know already I'm yeah
I'm sort of pushing the limit of my
pants and clothes here right now so
anyways back to the discussion Julian
dogs do not have sexy in layer six a bit
alright even if you win this argument I
won so alright alright you know what
dogs have sexy thank you ten to seven
Julian wins some of these are really
hard to argue because yes I think that's
part of part of the task and like the
exercise of this is arguing something
that you don't naturally feel inclined
to argue for because why would you ever
[ __ ] argue of dogs have sexy hands
well that's that's not what I was
referring to I actually believe that
that but um yeah like some of them I
don't know it's hard but it's fun I
actually enjoyed this is fun um thank
you guys for hanging out for another
podcast we appreciate it unless you have
any stronger arguments and also let us
know either for again how and what time
stamp I offended you this podcast just
know that it's not real not real most of
this is not real um this was a fun like
goofing around debating episode I hope
you guys enjoyed it thank you for
spending another week with us we'll see
you guys next week on a Jenna Julianne
we love you dink
[Music]